[Music]
yes thanks for the introduction by the
way and as you already mentioned I work
for babylon babylon is the healthcare
startup here in london and and today are
going to talk about disability
representation and i mentioned a bit on
how they are they work with chapels and
how they're basically a really nice tool
for to to to sort of understand what the
what the people are telling machines and
right so I wouldn't be really from a
start-up if I wouldn't start with like
some sort of ambitious vision and so
Babylon has this vision of putting an
accessible and affordable healthcare
service into the hands of everybody on
on earth right so this obviously
ridiculously ambitious and and it won't
simply work by taking a lot of doctors
and putting them in a room and putting
them on skype so you need to be much
more clever and in how you manage the
doctors how you manage access to the
services of doctors how you can how can
you reliably say if the patient doesn't
need to see a doctor things like that so
there's a the whole company is a big
push towards developing this technology
that allows us to so the semi automate
primary care and on one hand in the UK
but also in other countries like for
example Britain Rhonda as well and so so
if you want to automate primary care it
makes sense to look at what a doctor
actually does right and then we we sort
of have a skewed perception of that
because a lot of the things that the
doctor does are actually very simple for
us so from a machine point of view
though these very very simple skills
like understanding what you say and
having a conversation with you and like
visually inspecting what's wrong with
you and our nearly a bit harder than the
ones that we normally associated with
the doctor which is that the doctor
knows your history has some medical part
knowledge and that they can reason about
diseases and symptoms and so forth and
so I don't want to say we're not
interested in diagnosis right so we put
a lot of emphasis and a lot of resources
in the development of diagnostic systems
at problem and it's something very
interested in but day to day just if you
look at a doctor it's very cheap
little of his time spent actually
diagnosing from Machine point of view
actually this guy is already nearly
there right so the medics no never liked
that one a show that's right
and so the your aureus managed to gain
all the sort of standard skills that we
need so can understand language can see
everything we just need to instill a
little bit of medical knowledge into him
and then it will be doctor and the same
also holds therefore for like lawyers
and scientists and pretty much any any
profession that doesn't require some
sort of manual skill and from machines
point of view they all sort of share
these sort of same challenges right and
that is a good thing because this means
that a lot of people actually working on
these aspects so language understanding
computer vision and so forth and you've
seen some examples in the last talk
accomplished and the first three of
these and are actually clearly at the
moment at least in the domain of deep
learning so the who is so many with with
deep learning oh that's quite a few
nineteen might be bored and so these
three skills are sort of said the best
approach that we know is to use deep
learning on them so to use deep learning
for text understanding and focal
revision and so forth and yeah still far
from being solved so even though they
they're they don't get me wrong there
are amazing things that people do and
the amazing results but overall the
problem is still far from being solved
and and in digital health or nearly any
sort of application domain of machine
learning we need to understand that we
can take these advances from these sort
of more technical or more specific
applications of deep learning and
transfer them to like all our domain and
to to like sort of get you into or to
demonstrate what I believe is sort of
the best method of doing that and I want
to quickly revisit on what I believe
actually makes a deep new and network
work well ok so let's start
so this is like a standard new network
right so there's three layers input is
very poor the data there's a hidden
layer and then the output is where we
get our results right and there are is
the obviously the simplest possible way
of displaying this but there could be
some arbitrary sort of connectivity
between as many different layers many
disentitle is and one example how this
can be used is for example we take a lot
of pictures of cats and dogs or
something and and we want to train the
network to predict if each of the cat or
dog
so that's a bit and what we need to do
in order to do that is to to train a
network by showing it a lot of examples
so we showed millions of examples for
every one we tell them if you chose to
get a dog so far so good
nothing Medicare and but you all
probably know that there's something
going on in here that that makes them
work much better than other stuff and we
don't really understand what it is but
there's something that is going on these
in these hidden layers that actually
make them work much better than other
methods that people use so what do they
actually do right so you can think of
the newer network like this or as I say
any sort of arbitrary connectivity in
with more layers it's like a sequence of
two things the first is a sort of
complex nonlinear transformation of the
input and which feeds into this sort of
simple linear decision model that it's
in the end and this is really really
simple so it's like logistic regression
basically in the last layer if you have
a classification problem so when we
train a network initially it would be
pretty rubbish at the top that we wanted
to do right and and you're joining me
you sort of heavily penalize it
so we basically put them a lot of stress
they showed us examples and we sort of
things that you should do and and it
really wants to reduce the stress that
it's under and minimize sort of the cost
that we associate with its output and
and since the decision the decision part
is so simple the only thing you can
really do is over time to make these
representations
much more powerful well so I got word
wanting to update the best times and
so over time we basically force the
network to adjust the transformation of
the imitator in a way that makes it
easier for the decision models to do its
job and that sort of over the past
decade of machine learning research
I'd say the sort of one of the main
insights into why this interesting all
right and it's actually even if we have
something that works really well for
prediction the task might be so specific
that it's useless for anybody else but
the the fact that is it is able to do
this prediction has something to do with
this complex new information that we can
actually extract and use for the
purposes so you can think of the hidden
layer and as producing a vector
representation for an input for most of
you probably won't be surprised and so
let's say I put an image image at the
input then I can look at all the units
in my hidden layer and say on my last
hidden layer for example and treat them
as one vector right and basically just
along with the numbers so during
training we forced the network to
arrange things that are similar into
similar positions in this sort of high
dimensional vector space so it could be
a give it like this like a map right if
if I my cat and dog example if the
network is really good at classifying
pictures of care to pictures dogs it
will have somehow learn to separate
images of cats in this high dimensional
representation from other pictures for
example of so these are dogs actually
they're not cats in here don't want but
so genuine efforts are really good at
this they're really good at arranging
similar things in similar similar
locations in this high dimensional
vector representation and this can also
give us some sort of insight as to why
deeper networks tend to work better in
many applications so let's say I have a
fixed architecture then I sort of impose
a limit on how much the network can
transform the input in this
representation such that it's easy for
the decision model to decide so in many
cases it just won't work because it just
doesn't have enough flexibility to
arrange the things in a way that it
would like it to arrange and one way to
easily expand on the capability of
arranging things is by adding another
layer automatically we will we will
make it easier for the model to discover
transformations that are better to
represent the input for the decision
model so but we can't obviously do this
for images only we can also do this
other types of data and so and so apply
to language this idea has already led to
like a small revolution in like natural
language or something and we saw that
the as long as the network is good at
the task that it's trained for and the
task is sort of sensible it nearly
doesn't matter what task we use in order
we will always sort of get some sort of
in a sense useful hidden representation
in our network so applied your language
you can just define like a very simple
task right this is just like a toy
problem we want to classify whether a
sequence of words it's sort of sensible
or if it's nonsensical so for example
the capstan on the map is sensible and
again few on the map is not being
tentacle right and we just want to build
a network that can predict exactly this
yes or no and the way we do that it's a
very very simple model so we start by
looking at all of our capillary of words
and we assign one vector initially a
random vector two to each and every one
of the words in our vocabulary um and
these are usually represented the second
matrix and each row of the matrix is
like one represents one word and then
given sort of five words we sort of
build a simple model that concatenates
them for example or there are other ways
of combining them as well and then that
which feeds into like a very simple
decision part that just decides if it's
true or its false
right and the important thing is that
the task is sort of useless
all right nobody needs a classifier that
tells me if it's five a sequence of five
words is sensible or not nobody really
needs that but what is the crucial thing
is that we can with this simple toy task
getting easy that is very easy to get
millions and millions of training
examples from online data sources such
as Wikipedia and over
so and you probably all had a word to
Veck glove fast text all these sort of
different methods they all sort of share
any some aspects of this approach that
you have some sort of simple task and
that you just exploit to learn good
representations so what does it actually
what actually happens if you train this
so let's say you have a center the cat
sat on the mat right and I I look at
just the words set then they are just a
sort of finite number of words that I
can put into that spot such that the
sentence to make sense so it's all for
example the CAD lay on the mat the cat
slept on the mat they can't jumped on
the map of a bar so forth and the only
way the model can really solve this task
of predicting whether this is the
correct sentence or not is by by making
sure that all the words that would fit
in there and get a similar vector
representation right otherwise it can't
decide it and that leads to this sort of
interesting property that words that
have a similar context will obtain a
similar vector representation but
there's more to many of you this won't
come as a surprise but so this is a
picture from 2013 from paper from Thomas
McClure very seminal work and and what
it shows is four words that describe
countries and words that describe
capitols it's a projection down to the
first two principal components and what
you see is that it sort of learned a
systematic relationship between
languages on the left and kept it on the
right so what I mean by that is if you
started Poland for example and look at
the relation it is in with war so then
you see that it's kind of the same as
Russia to Moscow
so I could take this vector and apply to
this guy and I would sort of end up in a
similar region to Moscow and that's
really amazing right so the only by
looking at a whole lot of text I mean
it's a lot expert ill only by looking at
a road text to never learn something
about the world around it source you
know it learnt it learned actually to
make sense of some things and put things
into an order that is actually useful to
us and and but it's great for us
is that we can simply go back
so these representations so basically
these roles in these matrices after
training we can just take them out right
and use them for other things and the
key thing of these were to beg more
doors is that you just pay to throw away
this part never use it again and you're
just interested in these we're Pickers
so em I promised you a chapel demo so
and so I'm going to give you a quick
sort of feel for how this looks in
practice so how we can how you can use
these distributed representations to
actually make things sort of sensible
right and and this is basically a very
simplified explanation of how the chapel
works that we build a Babylon you know
if the practice is a bit more
complicated but never let's just give it
a try so let's say you want to build a
very simple shape of that and where you
want to answer questions to medical
questions with medical content that you
have on file alright so you know for
example if somebody says I have a
headache
I want to run them through like some a
little bit of like a decision tree sort
of questions or what to just give them
some information that's all things so um
let's say a user as a question about
headache and the simplest approach would
be to just come up with a bunch of rules
alright that's what everybody would do
so a user might say I don't know I have
a headache
my head hurts no no my pain in head and
they all these responses all these
questions should get sort of the same
response biobot and and you can come up
with bunch of rules maybe even regular
expressions and multiplicity eight
things that work well for a very small
fraction of the input data so what you
end up with it's like some sort of high
precision classifier that it's basically
very sure it's with its fires but it's
very low recall in that not a lot of
things fit to the patterns that you
described and and it's obviously a bit
boring but you could go on with this
pattern right you could you could have
more rules so what causes migraine my
leg hurts I've injured my arm injured my
leg all these different combinations you
could actually come up with a rule that
describes this and fire send a certain
response
and this is the reason probably why the
most popular Czech script sort of
libraries that you can you can find
online like rive scripts and chat
scripts and things again pretty much fit
this pattern so you define some sort of
pattern over of a elements in your
vocabulary and that I combine in some
way maybe it creates a part of speech
and since I got and using that you can
you can come up with these rules but
pretty quickly you reach the limit of
this alright so let's say even a
moderately complicated query like but I
don't know when I turn my neck the other
day my ear popped and it keeps ringing
what can I do it's very unlikely that
you defined a rule specifically for this
case right also it's quite unlikely that
you wrote a rule that it's generic
enough to fit this case because involve
things close relations and there's
simply no way in advance that you you
you you you know all the people will ask
for things and so you basically never
have enough rules in your sets to
actually do anything useful what you
need and is an additional level so after
the high position low RICO classify I
need something that sort of catches the
ones where you're not unsure about
things and that produces a response
still at some sort of some moderately
high quality and but the question is
also how do you do this right because
it's somehow it's tablished that we
can't use rules for this so we need to
use something else we need to make sure
that the that it sort of works for the
majority of the inputs that we give it
and and that we can sort of easily use
it right so what are the challenges
there so we need to generalize to
unknown stuff because we don't know it
we need to deal with messy inputs so we
have bad grammar since I got and and we
only have a limited amount of energetic
data so we're not Google or whoever so
we we don't have millions and millions
of examples we maybe have thousands and
thousands of examples but that it's
certainly not enough to build like a
very sophisticated machinery and so what
do we do ideally
and ideally we want something akin to
the word practice that we saw earlier so
we we would like something that has some
sort of high dimensional embedding space
right and we want to take take our
sentence and put it somewhere in their
meeting space
right and so I missed my paper which I
do would fly over there and similar
queries like my girlfriend forgot of
contraception would sort of ideally line
a sort of vicinity that it sort by so we
can sort of sort of see that they
similar and some other query like my
hoping to 10s or something should lie
ideally in a completely different space
in this and and it's actually it's
surprisingly powerful method for this
and something that I would recommend you
all try at home is to just use the
meeting word sector it sounds a bit
silly but if you take the sentence and
you just split it into words all right
and you look up all the words in your in
your model and you just use the mean
word vector so meaning you use some of
the word vectors that you divide by the
norm
- like divided by the links to normalize
it then this would pretty much do what
we just asked it to do all right
they actually papers with funny titles
like the taps to be baseline which is
pretty much just this approach with a
little bit more finesse but I would
highly recommend you try this at home
ideally when we have this so we have to
start mention space we have some sort of
sensible arrangement of queries then we
would just say trainer sort of very
simple model that says this part of the
space should go to this content and
these other parts of the spaces should
go to all the places sorted right so
it's really super super needy naive to
to propose model like it but it works
surprisingly well in practice as I can
maybe show you now let's see
so my nice anchor interface so this is
like a very simple version of a chap
order but just take one question and
we'll provide you with a couple of
different options for content that it
thinks is relevant for your question
okay
and can everybody read this noise yeah
and and the way it works is that it it
breaks up the send it into
tokens and generates this senator been
building and then there's some sort of
simple decision model at the top and it
has around a thousand different content
that it can deliver so let's just try so
I know let's try this example from the
sides miss Litella what should I do
right in this case the bot proposes that
I look at this content missing going to
have to fiddle and you can think that
then okay then the bot in the real life
would say so you tap it in in the bottle
say for getting taken to the fill it's
not necessary cause a problem
la-de-da-de-da try different ones so
very helpful and i don't know i i've a
cramp in my legs and which interested me
goes to mother concerts i so there's
some sense in this and go for the one so
mastic went away come I wonder what the
first one was anyway and so and you guys
any anybody any volunteers question come
on guys that's a good point
negation is really really hard and so
the problem is so okay restless leg
it's like close enough honey but and the
poly wait the point you mentioned which
I can see this is not in production
thank God it's not information
well at least everybody notice is not
scripted down no I wouldn't like
anything else I can't see my glasses
for some reason it wants to send it it
is the thing it's the embarrassing I
can't sleep that's much nicer that
sounds actually like the query that
people might have yeah and so in this
case I can't sleep actually goes to
insomnia and improving post leap which
is good but you can easily trick these
models right so so as I said this is the
the decision on where to put the
question in terms of content it's driven
by some data that we have and everything
that is not in your data obviously will
lead somewhere
right and I can promise you that if you
type that into our app that it was it
wouldn't recommend that content to you
but it's just a and this is really nice
right this is like 50 lines of Python
that runs this model and the training is
like you can do that in like an
afternoon to bid to build this sort of
engine so I just want to want to want to
say that this the assigning content of
potential pathways to users coming into
your chat board it's potentially really
easy if you if you're able to exploit
the the work vectors that you already
have on file is it can just download
from the web that incorporate all this
lingual it like English is one where all
the prior knowledge about the world
around us so you don't you don't
actually need to have that much training
data to build something that is
relatively powerful because you already
have this generalization ability
automatically built into your model
all right let's get it
get over here you can break this later
if you get some and so right so and
right and initially I wanted to talk
more about chat BOTS but and there's
actually one thing that we recently
released that I think it's a bit more
exciting right now which is on
multilingual word practice so um so far
I'm just talking about monolingual word
vectors so it basically only makes sense
to compare the similarity between two
words if they are from the same language
right if you train on the same corpus
otherwise it really sort of doesn't make
sense so
and there's a lot of interest though for
multilingual word vectors so meaning
things where I can compare two words in
the same language but also compared two
words across two languages right em and
so to give you some intuition on how
this could be done I want you to start
to this question so the first question
is so let's say let's say we take the
same data and we train word to back or
whatever method you use for these word
vectors we try and train on it twice
with different random C and what would
happen okay I want to give you an
analogy so say let's say there are some
undiscovered Pacific Islands that I'm
interested in right and and I take pick
two people they land on different
beaches on that island and I give them
some simple measurement tools all right
so they can measure distance and angles
and things like that and I give them a
task to draw a map okay and the I don't
to sort of big enough that they never
meet so they kind of talk to each other
about the maps that they draw what would
happen so if you can measure distance in
angles it's perfectly reasonable you end
up with a map that is reasonable right
the map itself the cosines between the
two maps will sort of match also the
maps are self consistent so the two
monuments basically in on the islands on
the the right map will have sort of the
same similarity relationship between
each other then the the same monument on
the other map and but there will be
thank you since I didn't give them a
compact there will be some sort of
random orientation between the two right
because there's no way of telling off so
intuitively what we can do is just
rotate the maps right so we can just do
this tada
and what we introduce it's some of the
sort of the the maps itself are still
the same they the pairwise relationships
within each of the maps is still the
same but we can now actually say that
this point in this map actually refers
to this point in this map it's not very
basic but
and the key thing is that this analogy
holds for word vectors so if you if you
would try and work on the same dataset
twice with different Rena seeds
it's basically akin to landing on the
different beaches the the measurement
tools that are used to create the map
are basically your learning algorithm
and the island itself is your data right
and what we just established basically
is to say that we say okay we need to do
a rotation which basically means that
there there should be some sort of
enough organ or linear transformation
between these two vector spaces that
minimizes some sort of norm which is
sort of the alignment of these cosines
and and crucially what happens if we do
this for these two different languages
right so right now we're just speaking
about single language right same data
but we previously said that the word
back has given enough data we'll sort of
model the world around us all right and
if you look at two languages let's say
English and Italian they both still
describe the same world around us so the
word break is joined on English and what
victim's friend an Italian should in the
end describe the same world around us so
the islands are the same even if there
are two languages so we can actually
intuitively speaking take a vector space
from English in the vector space from
Italian and just apply this orthogonal
transformation and we will be able to
align the two vector spaces of the two
languages and that is actually something
that actually works so we this paper
from us from we came out last week on
ITR and and in this paper we basically
shall be proof that this transformation
Shapiro Forman all right and we show
that there's actually an analytical
solution if you have a dictionary of
points that are basically the same so
think of monuments on those maps that
are mapped to each other then there's an
analytical solution that gives you the
optimal transformation between these two
vector spaces and so here's an example
so on the left hand side our word
vectors of English and Italian so say
blue is English red is Italian and you
see that before the alignment that sort
of bit random what
and while after the alignment you see
that document is sorted documental Kochi
narrows got the cooking that's a chair
it's got the putter jerry musica de
musica so it makes sense they're not lie
on exactly on top of each other but the
words that relate to each other will
rely in sort of a similar region of this
embedding space meaning we can actually
do the same tricks that we discussed
earlier we need this mean word vector
and so forth with this transform vector
space of multiple languages and it's
something you can actually download so
we Facebook recently published
initially 90 languages so which is the
word pre-trained word vectors for 90
languages they recently increased a
number to 294 avec and we created the
dictionary using google translate off
for like 78 of the 90 languages at the
time and we use the method that we
described in the paper to align all of
these different languages with English
and and in this repo you can actually
download all the other line of matrices
and a bit of code that helps you align
the vector spaces so you can you can
actually build much lingotek's plitivice
without much effort
thanks so I promise it's the only
possible that got them so so just to
illustrate all this so we have this
perspective you can download this you
can just load these Facebook word like
this in this case French and Russian and
you can calculate their similarity for
these two words alright and this guy
took the similarity sort of in the
middle right it's not a very similar not
dissimilar well if you apply this
transformation that we created to map
these two languages to English then you
can actually see that the similarity
between these two words increases quite
a lot and it's good because they both
mean cat it's not true
no that's that's French yeah thank the
government and and you can look at the
pairwise sort of translation precision
for individual words across all these
different languages so the the source
language is in the in the roles and the
target language in the columns and the
languages of the align with itself right
but there are some sub we need surprises
so if you if you align everything to
English you see that some pairs like off
diagonal pairs actually work really
really well so you have one examples
Russian and Ukrainian for example works
of like ninety percent precision it will
make sense but but to the computer it's
just words right it's like they don't
know that the the words are even spared
the same and it's an eye I don't have to
look it up so too tiny to reading for me
okay and it's a good question right and
I'm not sure if it's down to linguistic
similarity or if it's down to just that
the Wikipedia of both languages have
exactly the same content because the
people the translate from one to the
other also lots of them people so we
still investigating what sort of the
reason behind so I'm at the end story
and so thanks that was it we're hiring
machine learning scientists engineers if
you keen on working on cool stuff come
to us also patent us down the app thank
you
[Applause]
dr. Beck and so we have we haven't tried
dr. Berg we tried the other approaches
so they're a bunch of different
sentence-level and buildings that do
work but the so my experience what
actually works best is is in our name
right but it's sort of a trade-off
between the amount of effort that you
put in the speed at which you can do the
inference and the sort of improvement of
quality that you get so there are
obviously better ways of doing it
I am yep I didn't repeat I didn't repeat
the question there sorry so there they
are multiple the IMM take the questions
is we use islands in production and
virtual back in production so the the
chapel that we I can't exactly go into
the detail how it works right but the
overall the chapel that we have combines
multiple of these approaches all right
so so even though machine learning
people always tell you that you can
always do everything representing you
will always have a bunch of rules as
well so we have a bunch of rules at the
start right so just to capture cases
what we definitely - we have our own
ends deployed in production based on
what works and what they do is they
decide basically which path a user
should take through through like orchard
experience and we have additional models
like the one I just showed you that led
to like information retrieval basically
and and there there we used a variety of
different models including watch a mecha
saw like whatever grows really well
the question is on the seat back on the
doctors on the triple so we can't deploy
the chapel unless it's medically
validated so we have to convince the
doctors that it's safe which is a
challenge and but the the the we managed
to convince the doctors to deploy an RM
base chapel so they are happy with it
and in many cases if you build a system
that has a sort of probabilistic part to
it you need to make sure that even first
of all that the Senate sails gracefully
so if you think of a confusion matrix of
all your classes that it always confuses
with other compared to confusing between
the different classes that make sense
and you can achieve that through like
thresholds and like marginal position
things around and then you need to
design sort of the path the experience
so what the chapel says to be safe in
these cases where you fail and but that
is as much an interface problem as it is
it is a technical problem so yeah so so
you need a you need more more exam
earlier the question is if we need
basically if we need many examples for
the rotation and of the two vector
spaces so the dimensionality of this
vector spaces I should have mentioned
this is it's usually around three
hundred five hundred six hundred mark
and so you can determine that the it's
basically determined by a couple of
hundred examples but yeah there would be
an issue if you just have fifty examples
it probably won't work
and I'd say that something we're working
over now it is it is a bit difficult to
have a as I mentioned the the medical
validation of a chaplain is doable if
you if you have ever had the question
sorry I think the question was if the
chapel that we deployed learnt from in
the user over time associated some sort
of chronic conditions may be with
somebody asking the same thing over and
over again and I think for the for the
extra decision where it goes through the
system that is sort of secondary nearly
but there should be another process over
time that looks at at the the your
experience with the with the app that
then maybe highlights a certain risk of
chronic problems and that sort of so
what you sort of want is like a nearly
like a distributed representation for
patients that takes all this into
account and all the different
experiences that you have to the app
that is sort of sort of make you similar
and yeah so regarding sorry regarding
the the the validation of what I
mentioned earlier if you have a bob that
is too contextualized that where there
are too many too many ways of getting
into one pathway it becomes very
difficult to validate that pathway for
medical perspectives because there are
just so many different ways in can you
you can enter into it and so at the
moment we're still working on that too
yeah and so the questions if we evaluate
against like online support forums and
things are on and so regarding the NHS
triaging you mean the warm on one
service I guess they they do have an
issue that they're bit over overly
cautious into the freezing and days
there has actually been a deployment of
our triage ring system as a substitute
financials one one in London over the
last couple of months so we we do have a
triage system that performs with at
least as well a bit in our valuation so
far
and it's a bit less ever it's Saturday
and it won't always tell you to the GP
with people did people think that our
apple always recommend you to go to the
GP all right that's the typical
criticism that you when you have a chat
pod and you have an interaction and in
the end it says tell thirty-two called a
GP all right but on average it's more
expensive for us if you actually talk to
a GP may actually want you to not talk
to a GP freak and so the question is if
we use the video consultations to to
improve our increase of training time
and we don't do that at the moment and
there are some challenges regarding
information governance and privacy
security and so we we actually don't
have immediate access necessarily to the
recordings of of the the video of the
consultation right they would first have
to go through like a like a quite
stringent analyzation process and it so
we at the one we don't not using that
yet then we basically have a lot of
inner doctors that help us with an
initial data collection and we have some
of the services that we offer also
involve speaking to a clinician via text
so that it's an obvious source for for
training data for us
so and fast text works particularly well
for for for languages that have like
composited words so that the way fast
texts work that is that it's different
to what effect is that that beyond just
learning a representation for the words
it tries to to learn representations for
basically trigrams or engrams in general
where the mean over those engrams is
sort of similar to the to the
representation of the word said that is
made up of these trigrams and what that
leads to is that it's it's better at
like words that are rare which is pretty
much all the cases for languages where
word can be freely like German where you
can just put lots of words in a sequence
and it might be a combination that you
have not seen that often in your
training set you would still have a good
prior what the representation should be
been yet fast but these are these are an
inference time they're all the same it's
just that it's just a hashed right so
you just look up a value in - so an
infant's time there's no benefit in
depth to speak
[Applause]
[Music]